the idea is is this is mastery
appropriate to a totally modern world
which isn't the world of da Vinci or I
even Einstein I find it almost a it's a
good question but it's almost a silly
idea because we humans have evolved over
the course of millions of years the
human brain is a masterpiece of design
from our earliest ancestors to the
earliest Homo sapiens to the invention
of language to who we are now and to
think that in 20 years we have somehow
overthrown 5 6 million years of
evolution is just absolutely ridiculous
the brain is what it is it has a certain
pattern a certain I call it a grain to
it it's an instrument that is designed
if you focus deeply on a subject you
understand it better and better and
better and more layers of it are
revealed to you you can't suddenly
rewrite the configuration of the human
brain or imagine that by surfing quickly
from here there on the internet you're
somehow going to become a master of
something so the laws that I'm talking
about in the book about focus about
going deeply into us into a subject they
still pertain but we give it a modern
flavor so I interviewed nine
contemporary masters to get rid of the
notion that these are all people in
powdered wigs masters on the 18th
century whatever all of them fit the
same pattern that I'm talking about but
they've managed to use what's great
about our time period the level of
distraction is a negative let's face it
it is a negative it's it makes it harder
for us to go deeper and deeper into a
subject or to focus deeply but the good
parts of our era is the incredible
explosion of information how much is
accessible to us how it's just a couple
of clicks on the internet we can start
investigating some new science or some
new discovery and just at our fingertips
it's it's incredible and so these are
all people who are taking advantage of
all
this and our making connections between
ideas between different fields that's
where the future of mastery is yoky
Matsuoka she goes into electrical
engineering and then she goes into
robotics and now she's and she studied
neuroscience so she's combined them all
into a new field called new robotics
where she's trying to design products
that have that operate like a robot but
are linked to how the human brain works
so that they're things that learn she's
combined five or six different fields
into this new field that she calls new
robotics that's the future of mastery
but you have to master the basics of the
whole thing which is building discipline
being able to practice at something over
a long period of time and being able to
focus nothing we ever invent is going to
be able to change that there's no drug
in the world or or any application
that's going to alter none
you
[Music]